Senator Jeff Flake from Arizona says
that President Trump is Stalin Eskin his
approach to the press the Democrats
continue to go bizarrely insane over
president Trump's bleep whole comments
plus we may be about to find out what
President Trump is like down there and
I'm not talking about his hands oh god
no please god no
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
yes indeed The Daily Beast is now
reporting that stormy Daniels she of the
180 IQ and the presumably large breasts
and she's a porn star she apparently had
an affair with President Trump back in
2006 and now they are going to run a
5500 word interview with her about her
sexcapades with Trump they'll discuss
the impact of this and just screaming
over and over and over then trying to
gouge out our eyes before this interview
can come out but before we do any of
those wonderful things first we're gonna
say thank you to our sponsors over at
zip recruiter because once my eyes are
actually out of my head I can no longer
read advertisements so we'll make sure
that we read the ads before I actually
gouge my eyes out of my head so zip
recruiter is the place that you want to
go if you need to recruit better help if
you need better people working at your
office that's why we're constantly using
zip recruiter to upgrade our staff it's
a wonder that our original staff any of
them are still here considering the
quality of candidates that we get from
zip recruiter they post your job total
100 of the web's leading job boards with
just one click and then zip recruiter
actively looks for the most qualified
candidates and invites them to apply
they even review every application to
identify those top candidates so you
never miss a terrific match and that's
why as hip recruiter is different they
do not depend on the right candidates
finding you it finds them for you no
wonder 80 percent of employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day zip
recruit is the small smartest wait to
hire it works for businesses of all
sizes in all industries right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free right just for free go to zip
broker comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash daily when you do
you can post jobs for free again zip
recruiter comm slash daily where we use
it here at the daily wire offices it has
brought us at least a couple of
employees that I know about and and we
continue to post a zip recruiter
whenever we have an opening so check it
out at zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire ok so we begin with this just
breaking story that stormy Daniels is
now going to drop a long story about how
she had sex with Trump in 2006 and we're
all supposed to act surprised over all
of this the answer is no none of us are
surprised over any of this president
Trump's character has long been known
his latest wife Melania the First Lady
of the United States is his third wife
he was having an affair with her one
who's married
second wife he was having affair with
his second wife when he was married to
his first wife
so no none of this is particularly
surprising also he obviously has a thing
for models Melania was working for a
modeling agency that I believe he ran at
the Tyler that he owned at the time that
they were married and posing in shall we
say provocative ways and and then he
said that he married her specifically
because he wanted to make other men feel
jealous when he walked into the room so
it's not particularly surprising the
Trump apparently had an affair while
Melania was pregnant with Barron in 2006
so in touch magazine has now run
excerpts from an interview with adult
film star stormy Daniels for actual name
is Stephanie Clifford wherein she
detailed having this affair so
apparently she he approached her in in a
golf tournament in Lake Tahoe in July
in 2006 rather just four months after
youngest son Barron was born he and he
asked for her number and invited her to
dinner when she arrived he was wearing
sweat pants and they ended up eating in
his hotel room which is just a classy
move I mean when I'm that that was my
typical seduction move but I when I
first met my wife I showed up in
sweatpants looking with the homeless
person and then I said you want to go
upstairs it works great she excused
herself to the bathroom when she emerged
Daniels told in touch the Trump was
sitting on the bed and invited her to
join him she thought oh here we go and
then she went through it in anyway
because apparently this is what people
do I'm completely bewildered by the sex
habits of rich and famous people I know
that now I'm somewhat rich and also
somewhat famous but I'm still bewildered
by this hi this has not changed my view
of sex is supposed to work apparently
according to The Daily Beast the full
unedited interview that will run later
this week is five thousand five hundred
words of cray so we can all look forward
to that apparently she is going to drop
full-on explicit descriptions of the
president's junk so this will make the
second president in the last four about
whose junk we know far too much so
that's going to be very exciting I'm so
glad that the media are on top of this
thing meanwhile Senator Jeff Flake is
right now taking to the floor of the
Senate to rip president Trump over his
treatment of the press I'm very
disappointed because today if you recall
was supposed to be the day when we were
gonna get the fake news Awards it was
supposed to be last week then it was
delayed till today and now it has been
downgraded to a potential idea so it
turns out the fakest news was that there
was a fake news awards that is not
actually taking place but Jeff Flake
took to the floor of the Senate flank
of course is leaving the Senate he was
probably not gonna win reelection
probably gonna lose his primary in
Arizona anyway so he is leaving but not
before he throws a few brick bats at his
fellow Republicans and at president
Trump over his treatment of the press
some of this is earned a lot of it is
Jeff Flake posturing
here is what flake had to say no longer
can we turn a blind eye or a deaf ear to
those assaults on our institutions and
mr. president an American president who
cannot take criticism who must
constantly deflect and distort and
distract who must find someone else to
blame is charting a very dangerous path
in a Congress that fails to act as a
check on the president adds to that
danger yeah the idea that Congress has
not checked the president wondering how
they're supposed to check him when he
says dumb stuff like fake news about
things that are not fake news now we'll
get a little bit later to actual fake
news you know the how the media have
covered for example president Trump's
health the suggestion that he is
demented or that he is in the early
stages of Alzheimer's that he's totally
crazy or that he's about to die of a
heart attack
all of this nonsense and that was proved
on since yesterday by a doctor for the
White House was evaluated presidents
going all the way back to Obama and and
who basically gave Trump a clean bill of
health and media refused to accept that
but the idea that Congress is is sort of
sitting around doing nothing when Trump
says bad things I'm wondering where is
this purported silence I'm hearing so
much about
I keep hearing their silence when Trump
says stupid stuff about the media well
I'm not silent I know a lot of
Republicans who aren't silent Democrats
certainly aren't silent the media
certainly aren't silent that Jim Acosta
certainly is in silent even when Trump
just throws - even when Trump does
something that's not terribly wrong -
Jim Acosta Jim Acosta is on CNN
whining about it the White House
correspondent for CNN
for example this happened yesterday with
regard to the media here is Trump was
being asked questions by a cost Acosta
just won't shut up and finally Trump
says get out Jim Acosta mr. president
just say that you want more people to
come in from Norway did you say that you
wanted more people to come in from
Norway is that true mr. president I want
him to come in from everywhere
everywhere thank you very much everybody
just Caucasian or white countries sir do
you want people to come in from other
parts of the world where they're people
of color
and not sure if you can hear the end of
that there wolf but as I tried to ask
whether he wanted more people to come in
just from white or Caucasian countries
he said out he pointed at me and said
out as and get out of the Oval Office
okay and then he says out he says out to
a Cossack has a costume won't show up
and then Acosta goes online and whines
about it on Twitter oh he said out to me
yes I'm sure Jim it was just like the
journalists who are being jailed in
China this idea that the media are being
somehow stonewalled by the Trump
administration it's the leakiest
Administration in American history and
from loves the press I mean he's talking
to the press on a non-stop basis Jim
Acosta playing the victim is just a
little bit silly you know I think that
the president should not say what he
says about the press I've said that many
times I've said it throughout the
campaign I've said that the attacks on
the fake news media are ridiculous
attacked the fake news when it's
actually fake news don't attack it when
it's not fake news but the idea that
Trump is doing something you know that
is under there that is undeniably
destroying the image of the press among
the American people pretty sure the
press did that themselves and they
continued to do it themselves on a
fairly regular basis and just to finish
with flake here's what flake had to say
about politicians attacking the press
and so we know well that no matter how
powerful no president will ever have
dominion over objective reality no
politician will ever get us there tell
us what the truth is and what it is not
and anyone who presumes to try to attack
or manipulate the press for his own
purposes should be made to realize his
mistake and to be held to account that
is our job here that is just as Madison
Hamilton and Jay would have it isn't I'm
fine with criticisms of President Trump
that are earned again I think that flake
making a big deal out of from suit acts
on the press why don't we wait for like
an actual Trump attack on the press that
is worthwhile this is a pre-planned
speech that he was announcing five days
in advance how he was gonna go after
Trump from the Senate floor this for
like sort of wants to run for president
it was bad timing for him because this
is the same press that is busily going
after Trump's health so as I mentioned
White House doctor yesterday said there
are no concerns about Trump's cognitive
abilities here he had to stay at the
White House is that I watched some of
his press conference live went on for
like an hour
him just talking about the president's
help dr. Ronnie Jackson the presidential
position and the press just cannot
believe that Ronnie Jackson is giving
frump a clean bill of health and not
declaring him a nut so I had no
intentions whatsoever doing that like I
said because I didn't feel it was
clinically indicated and part of the
reason I didn't think it was clinically
indicated is because I've spent almost
every day in the president in the
president's president since January 20
2004 you know last year when he when he
got into office and I've seen him every
day I seen one two sometimes three times
a day because of the location of my
office we have conversations about many
things most of not most don't revolve
around medical issues at all but I've
got to know him pretty well and I had
absolutely no concerns about his
cognitive ability or his you know his
neurological function so I was not gonna
do a cognitive exam I had no intention
of doing one the reason that we did the
cognitive assessment is plain and simple
because the president asked me okay so
so Trump took the cognitive assessment
he scored 30 out of 30 on that and the
Pres couldn't believe it and in just a
second I'm gonna tell you what the press
did about it this morning because it's
it's just a mantra of the fact that this
is not a one-sided battle it's not just
from taking on the press it so obviously
the press also taking on Trump in some
pretty ridiculous ways first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker so you need to find your keys
you need to find your wallet right this
is just an exercise that I used to go
through every single day I'm on my way
out of the house where's my wallet
where's my keys my kids stole them and
hid them somewhere how do I find them
well the best way that you can find them
now is with the tracker pixel because
you'll never have to worry about losing
your things again it's the lightest
Bluetooth tracking device on the market
you put the tracker pixel on whatever
you tend to lose your keys your wallet
your purse and then you install the app
on your phone and you can use your phone
to find your keys your wallet your purse
or if you lose your phone then you can
use your keys while in a purse you hit
the the tracker pixel and actually rings
through on your phone so this is a
common complaint around in Shapiro
household or was the idea that you lose
your phone it's on silent you're trying
to ring it and you don't know where it
is well when you have the tractor pixel
it just over rules that it makes a sound
from your phone even if your phone is on
silence and that ensures that you can
find your phone even though you put it
on silent and then forgot to take it off
silent later when you misplace an item
that has a tracker pixel attached again
a 90 decibel alert helps you find it in
seconds and you can even locate your
item if it's miles away because every
a current user is part of the largest
crowd locate network in the world so
it's kind of like Waze except for
finding things they also have a 30-day
money-back guarantee which means you
really don't have anything to lose so
check it out save 20% off your order
when you go to the track are calm it's
the track are calm / been again the
track are calm / Bend for 20% off the
track are calm / been I said before it
has been a saving grace in my marriage
it has definitely helped relations in
the Shapiro household because there's
nothing worse than you're late for a
dinner reservation and now you have
spent 15 minutes looking for your car
keys or my wife's phone which is what
she usually loses it has definitely
alleviated a lot of the stresses in the
Shapiro house thank God those are the
definite sense of the stresses in our
house but it's it's stressful
nonetheless which is why the track are
so great the track are calm / Ben for
20% off and it lets them know that we
sent you okay so I was talking about
Jeff Flake suggesting the Trump's
attacks on the media are bad yes they
are bad I don't like them and he said
that they he said that they inspired
dictators around the world inspire is
too strong a word the idea that that the
mullahs are sitting around in Iran going
ah now Trump attacked the press wish I
had thought of that oh now I must not
talk press like I don't know what that
accent was but I certainly don't know
where that logic would come from so the
idea that they are there sitting around
you know Kim Jong loon is sitting around
thinking to himself yes Trump attacked
the press now I'll be mean to the press
just stupid the idea that it emboldened
people because Trump isn't going to
stand up for press freedoms in other
parts of the world there's probably some
elements of truth to that but when Trump
attacks the news it makes it easy for
him to attack the news when the media
decide to be idiot so as I mentioned
yesterday dr. Ronnie Jackson is the
presidential physician and it came out
and cleared Trump on health he also
cleared him on heart health he said that
Trump has excellent genes that the best
genes the greatest genes here's doctor
Randy Jackson talking about Trump's
amazing James it's called genetics I
don't know it's some people have you
know just great genes you know I told
the president that if you had a
healthier diet over the last 20 years he
might live to be 200 years old I don't
know I mean he he has incredible he has
incredible genes okay so obviously the
president wants the doctor out there
saying that which is fine there's all
these conspiracy theories going around
now about Trump's height and weight
people are calling them girth hers and
center birthers because the the health
report suggested that President Trump
ways to
thirty nine pounds into six three and
four years he'd been saying that he was
six two so apparently he gains an inch
and that inch sort of prevented him from
being labeled as obese as opposed to
overweight as though it makes any sort
of difference but here's the point his
dad I think Fred Trump lived to
something like 93 I believe let me let
me see he he yeah he lives home 94 Fred
93 I was right the first time Fred Trump
lived til 93 Trump is only 71 now so
just based on life expectancy and
families who'd be likely that Trump does
fine right that Trump lives fine so the
the doctor comes out and he says the
Trump does not suffer from a heart
disease well today Sanjay Gupta over at
CNN came out and say well hold on a
second he does suffer from heart disease
Trump does have heart disease now Sanjay
Gupta has not actually examined a Trump
he doesn't really know much about from
self other than what Ronnie Jackson said
but the media have jumped on this and
now they're suggesting well maybe maybe
people weren't forthright about all this
maybe it turns out that maybe it turns
out that that Trump business is healthy
is we were led to believe oh this is
wishful thinking because media actually
hope that he dies I mean let's be blows
to be frank about that so a lot of
members of the media who hope that term
stops drops dead tomorrow
of a heart attack here's what Jackson
actually said about Trump's heart
disease he said he said he does not have
heart disease he and the question was he
had a CT scan before the chod calcium in
his coronary blood vessels and Jackson
said he does he did he had technically a
non non clinical arthrosclerosis
coronary arthrosclerosis and so that's
been mentioned in previously previous
physical exams he's had done had a
coronary calcium score done in 2009 it
was 34 he had a coronary calcium score
done in 2013 it was 98 and then we did
get a calcium score from this one I
didn't mention it because I think it was
clinically good information it was 133
so I had a conversation with the
cardiologist not only at Walter Reed but
at Cleveland Clinic and several other
well-known institutions everyone saw
that is reassuring he's gone this period
of time and he's had that little of a
change in his coronary calcium load so
Sanjay Gupta says well he's suffering
from coronary heart disease right so
technically he is right so technically
pretty much everyone is he scored 133
according to the the the WebMD carry a
calcium scoring chart that means they
have a moderate amount of plaque in your
heart you have heart disease and plaque
may be blocking an artery your chance of
having a heart attack is moderate to
high
but it also depends on your age so if
you actually go over to the multi-ethnic
study of atherosclerosis which is an
actual study that you can type in your
information like your your your age and
your race and your and your gender when
you type in 71 year old white male and
133 calcium score that calculates that
you are a that you are in the 46
percentile right say basically around
average right that's kind of normal for
your age into in terms of in terms of
what you have plus Trump's calcium score
has been stable over time in 2009 he was
at the 47th percentile in 2013 he was at
the 52nd percentile today he's actually
at the forty second at the 46th
percentile so he's actually doing better
now than he was in 2013 by percentile in
other words his heart is not getting bad
as fast as other people his age their
hearts are getting bad so the media are
obviously over blowing this and trying
to make it seem like Trump is on the
verge of having a massive heart attack
and and they're suggesting that you use
the I test ok Trump is fat Trump doesn't
exercise he doesn't eat well all of that
is true it's also true that a lot of
people who don't eat well and are fat
and have good genes live till really old
ages without actually having heart
attacks it happens all the time George
Burns smoked and live til 101 that
doesn't say smoking is good for you but
it does suggest that not every average
means that you're going to be the guy
who has the heart attacks the media I
made a huge deal out of all of this in
the same way that they made a huge deal
out of the bleep all comments and the
goal of all of this is to make it seem
as though Trump in some way or another
is unfit for office so I've said before
I think that Trump does not have the
character I would wish to see in the
President of the United States but the
media's attempt to recast Trump's health
records as a real issue now it's just
insane and that's one of the reasons why
people don't take the media seriously
when Trump attacks the media which he
does so often and so repeatedly so
meanwhile obviously the S whole
controversy has now entered its sixth
day and this will not end I again harken
back to that time when the Obama
administration when President Obama
specifically said about an allied Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu that he was
chicken bleep and that controversy lasts
in under 24 hours I remember because I
was there and helps cover it the the
bleep whole controversy continues
because the media wants portrayed Trump
as a racist and not only do they want
him to portray him as a racist they also
want to use that portrayal in order to
blame from for any breakdown on attack a
deal
so Trump yesterday came out and he sort
of clarified his policy on all this he
says listen regardless of what you think
you've heard from behind closed doors
here's my policy
I want a merit-based system the
merit-based system is based on who is
highly educated who is highly skilled
now there are a lot of people who are
coming out and saying well a merit-based
system is in and of itself
discriminatory because there are people
from different countries who are less
educated and Trump is really saying he
wants white people because white people
from European countries are gonna have
higher levels of education on average
than say people from Haiti and who cares
you know three generations ago my ground
and great-grandfather came here and he
had no education and he did great well
that's true I mean three generations ago
my great-grandfather came here in 1907
and he did grade two he didn't speak
didn't speak the language I'm not sure
his educational level was the difference
is there wasn't a massive social safety
net and redistributionist Network that
was designed to pick up the slack for
him if he failed the idea was that we
were self selecting better immigrants in
terms of people who are entrepreneurial
because they knew you come here you're
not hands in anything and if things go
wrong you're basically on your own right
these are risk seeking people who came
over to the United States in an attempt
to better themselves it's not the same
thing as people who are coming over here
for redistribution and even if you're
saying people are coming here to better
their lives they're not coming here for
redistribution if you know there's a
social safety net that is going to
change the level on average of people
who are coming into the country just the
way you're going to change the clientele
of your restaurant if you say that it's
a hundred bucks a plate
whereas if you say all the food is free
that's gonna change who shows up for
your restaurant there's a difference in
a soup kitchen and a five-star Michelin
Rathod rated restaurant so the idea that
that you are you can change the state
how the United States works and not
change the nature of immigration coming
to the United States which necessitates
a change in the standard that you're
using for immigration is just le so here
is Trump saying listen I want to
immigrants from everywhere but I want a
merit-based system I just want to thank
everybody for being here did you say
that you wanted working thank you very
much
thank you very much I want him to come
in from everywhere everywhere thank you
very much everybody to the left should
be jumping on that and saying okay well
there's from são Paulo G right if there
are smart what they would say is we want
a merit-based system too and that's why
what Trump said about Haitian immigrants
is so terrible because there are plenty
of Haitian immigrants who'd be great
here and then instead they they won't
say that they don't want a merit-based
system they do want to discriminate on
the basis of country of origin it's one
of the big problems and they continue to
rip on the Trump administration as
though the Trump administration is on
the verge of deporting all the dreamers
I know that's the dream of many of the
hardliners in the Republican caucus and
a few members of the sort of Ann Coulter
Breitbart base but the reality is that's
not what Trump is discussing right now
Christian Nielsen is the Secretary of
Homeland Security and she was
specifically asked yesterday in a
hearing whether the Trump administration
was looking to deport so-called dreamers
these would be people who are brought
here as young people through quote
unquote no fault of their own and now
they've been here for nearly their
entire lives here's what Nelson had to
say it's not going to be a priority of
the Immigration and Customs Enforcement
to prioritize their removal I've said
that before that's not the that's not
the policy of DHS so if this doesn't get
worked out and I am a dreamer the way
I'm supposed to read what you just said
is this is not going to be a priority of
Vice if you are a daca
that's compliant with your registration
meaning you haven't committed a crime
and you in fact are registered you're
not priority of enforcement for ice
should the program end okay so what
she's what she's saying is basically
daca is gonna remain in place even if
Congress doesn't do anything about it
which suggests that the two sides are
really not that far apart on this thing
Republicans just want some of trumps
immigration priorities put in place but
Democrats have no interest in providing
that because in all likelihood we're not
gonna deport these folks in any case so
why are the media going so nuts over
this why are they going to nuts over the
bleep hole comment when the policy is
basically so consistent when it appears
that nothing really is going to change
because obviously they're trying to get
the Republicans to cave on all of their
political priorities and I'm gonna show
you how that's the case in just a second
Plus Cory Booker just loses his mind I
mean absolutely loses his mind it's the
greatest case of acting since jon lovitz
I mean it's acting it's amazing and I
haven't been this moved by a piece of
acting that I've seen recently since
since Tommy Wiseau it's just incredible
so we'll get to that in just
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Bull and branch so
you know people don't agree on
everything but I think that everyone can
agree that you need a good night's sleep
I definitely need a good night's sleep I
value my sleep I Lee and that's why I
need bull and branch everything bull and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft and as
you wash them they get even softer over
time and you are buying directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks in stores but
bull and brand sheets are only a couple
hundred bucks the sheets are so good
that I've bought a bunch of pairs on my
own we put them basically all the rooms
of our house we put them in the kitchen
because they're so comfortable I mean
they're just they're supremely
comfortable when I'm at a hotel on the
road I don't sleep as well because they
don't always have bullet and branch
sheets everyone who tries these sheets
loves them that's why three
ex-presidents sleep on them Plus Bill
Clinton's lovers presumably to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
Beau and branch comp promo club and Plus
by the way shipping is free and you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them then you send them back and you get
a full refund you're not gonna want to
send them back they are that good right
now listeners as I say 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
com promo Claire bennigan that's bull
and branch comm promo code been 450
bucks off your first set of sheets of Bo
LL and branch comm promo code Ben go
ahead and check it out Bolin Brad comm
promote Club Ben and that lets them know
that we sent you as well again 50 bucks
off your order alright so the question
is Trump is signaling he wants a
merit-based system I put aside the bleep
hole comments because those happened a
week ago and a new cycle speak that's
like basically new cycle speak is sort
of like dog ears right every week is
seven years in new cycle speaks so a new
cycle speak this happened a long time
ago we're still talking about it why are
the Democrats still keeping it alive
because they're more interested in using
it as a club to beat Trump than actually
coming to some sort of agreement over
data so here's the DHS secretary
yesterday testifying in front of the
Senate Judiciary is the Senate Judiciary
Committee I believe and she says she's
not gonna talk about these comments and
then Democrats lose their freakin minds
at any point in that conversation on
Thursday did the president United States
use that four-letter word in with us in
combination with any other words or
alone that you heard there respectfully
I have answered this I've been very
patient with this line of questioning I
am here to tell you about the threats
our country faces and the needs and
authorities that are needed by the
department of homeland security if
nothing further to say about a meeting
that happened over a week ago I'd like
to move forward and discuss ways in
which we can protect our country okay
and this promise the Democrats to just
go not so Kamala Harris our awful awful
senator from the state of California she
suggests that the secretary herself
might be a racist because there's what
we're gonna do now we're just gonna
we're gonna race bait all the way all
the way till the end again I thought
Trump's comments were at best
ill-advised and at worst reeks of racism
I think there's a plausible
interpretation that does not have
anything to do with race I think that in
in my opinion that may be the slightly
more plausible interpretation but the
idea the Secretary's racist is insane it
doesn't matter she suggests that the
secretary is racist anyway this is a
pivotal moment in the history of our
country is it when we are having
discussions about whether the people of
Norway and I will use your words Madam
Secretary and you spoke about how they
were referred to as by contrast to the
people of Africa and the various country
the 54 countries of Africa and Haiti and
we speak of them and you spoke of them
according to the President as the people
of Norway well you know they work very
hard
the inference being the people of the 54
states of Africa and Haiti do not you
must understand the inference the
reasonable inference that the American
public is drawing from the words you
speak much less the words of the
President of the United States so now
she's suggesting that Nilson is a racist
so everyone's a racist right Nelson is
sitting there basically saying I didn't
hear those comments maybe she's lying
maybe that's not for maybe she didn't
hear the comments it doesn't matter the
bottom line is she didn't say anything
in this hearing those racist Kamala
Harris is gonna keep screaming racism so
that nobody actually has to discuss what
to do with the dreamers and the truth is
that Trump doesn't want to talk about
the dreamers Trump basically was willing
to cut any deal that he could cut at the
very beginning until the spine stiffener
was put in him by Tom cotton as well as
as well as a couple of other senators
but the Democrats lost their minds
history so Cory Booker just goes nuts I
mean he goes full-on John
it's acting course crazy here I mean
it's Lisa is tearing him apart I mean he
just he goes he goes ballistic and he's
bad at this I mean really bad at this
this is not even good acting he says he
cried tears of Rage tears of rage I'm
gonna talk a little bit about tears in
politics in just a second because I hate
this crap
but here's Cory Booker just putting on
his mr. Potato Head angry eyes in order
to in order to rip into Nilson and Trump
in an oval office meeting referring to
people from African countries and
Haitians with the most vile and vulgar
language the language Fester's when
ignorance and bigotry is allied with
power it is a dangerous force in our
country your silence and your amnesia is
complicity right now in our nation we
have a problem I don't know if 73
percent of your time is spent on white
supremists hate groups I don't know if
73 percent of your time is spent
concerned about the people in fear in
communities in this country Sikh
Americans Muslim Americans black
Americans the fact pattern is clear of
the threats in this country I hurt where
dick durbin called me I had tears of
rage when I heard about this experience
in that meeting and for you not to feel
that pain and that pain and to dismiss
some of the questions of my colleagues
saying I've already answered that line
of questions with tens of billions of
Americans are hurting right now because
of what they're worried about what
happened in the White House that's
unacceptable to me
you're out of order this entire Court is
out of order never go full al pacino and
injustice for all never do it it's just
not good and so Cory Booker of course
the left loves this sort of
theatricality they love the Afrika leti
and deception just like Ra's al Ghul
they're totally into it
they love Cory Booker yeah I mean it's
it is Tommy Wiseau level acting like
just look at carries the it's the
greatest acting I've seen since I saw
this
[Music]
yeah can I have a dozen red roses please
oh hi Johnny I didn't know what you here
you go that's me how much is it it'll be
$18 go keep the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye bye bye I did not hit
her it's not true it's both did not hit
her I did not oh hi mark yep there it is
okay there it is that's it there it is
there is your there is your cory booker
moment from tommy wiseau I didn't you
did not hit me oh hi secretary Nelson
like what is this what is this nonsense
then all this posturing you think
they're really you think if you think
Cory Booker cried tears of Rage first of
all man up dude Craig tears of Rage you
do politics for a living you know how
many times I've ever cried about
politics itself this many times zero I
do it every day I'm doing it every day
since I was 17
people say horrible crap all the time
not just about politics generally but to
me specifically and then Cory Booker
talks about I get death threats yeah
I've been there you know many times I
whined about that in front of the Senate
Judiciary Committee
maybe that oh my god first of all what a
secretary Nilson have to do with death
threats the Cory Booker received I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to hear the
explanation on that one I'll also point
out here that it lets say for example
that Hillary Clinton had been testifying
in front of Republicans and they had
started yelling at her the way Cory
Booker was just yelling at secretary
Nelson it's suggesting that your silence
is complicity hey going full-on nutjob
with it with the with the Pan's
Labyrinth hands up here right oh I'm a
moose right that that's basically what
what cory booker is doing there he does
this this insane routine imagine that
we're republicans doing it to a democrat
woman with the cries of sexism ever stop
we're still hearing about she persisted
because elizabeth warren wouldn't be
quiet after she was told to be quiet by
the rules of the senate and then it was
oh she persisted she put what a brave
woman would have brave limba cory booker
rips this lady up and down for basically
doing nothing right and you know what a
hero he is what a hero in the this sort
of this sort of nonsense just makes me
sick to my stomach it's really stupid
and it's really gross in its really
opportunistic cory booker wants to run
for president so does Kamala Harris
maybe they'll have a cry off somebody
call them
I'm gonna talk a little bit more about
crying in politics in just a second
because this is I hate emotions as a
general rule and I particularly hate it
when it comes to emotions in politics
but first we are going to have to break
over at Facebook so check us out at
Daily wire comm and get a subscription
$9.99 a month buys you subscriptions
who's daily where when you do you get
the rest of our show which is going to
be awesome today
you get the rest of Andrew Clavin show
the rest of Michael Moses show you get
to be part of the mailbag you could have
been part of Andrew clavin's mailbag
yesterday on the conversation if you
would subscribe but you didn't and now
you're feeling bad about yourself well
that's why you need to go and subscribe
right now this very minute for $9.99 a
month also the annual subscription comes
along with those things and this the
magnificent incomparable never imitated
never duplicated leftists tears hot or
cold mug it was perfect for Cory Booker
yesterday I legitimately turned on my TV
opened up this mug and magically just
filled up from the bottom of the top
with Cory Booker's tears of rage I then
I then had to boil them down so that the
water was not as says that it was
sanitary because I don't actually like
to drinking other people's here seems
kind of gross I don't know what's going
on in their pours but just general rule
not cory booker specific but in any case
the tumbler is great and for $99 a year
you can have that as well as all the
other goodies so check that up you want
to listen later iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube subscribe to our YouTube channel
we always have good new videos coming
out so check that out over there we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so it used to be that in American
politics you weren't supposed to cry it
was a sign of weakness to cry in
American politics it showed that you
were a wimp it showed that you couldn't
handle the stress of high office now if
you don't cry you are considered not in
touch with your feelings I like it
better the old bleh I don't want my
leaders to cry and there are times by
the way when it seems entirely
appropriate for me to for people to cry
like if you see a wounded soldier you're
in a situation where you see a suffering
child these are times when you cry
you're walking through a Holocaust
Memorial where there are times where
tears I think are not out of bounds but
the idea that you cried when you heard
because the president said that there
are some bleep whole countries women
that just tears of rage first of all it
sounds like a really terrible romance
novel from Danielle Steel tears of rage
with Korey Booker but let's go back to
1972 so all the way back in 1972 there
was a there was a candidate for the
presidency of the United States and the
Democratic Party his name was Edmund
muskie okay Edmund muskie was actually
one of the frontrunners for the
nomination he was the 58th Secretary of
State under Jimmy Carter he was a
senator from Maine from 1959 to 1980 and
he was considered somebody who was
probably gonna run strong in the 1972
election cycle so the polls for him were
pretty good he was considered a
front-runner in in 1970 he declared that
he was going to run in the Iowa caucuses
however George McGovern one and then
muskie ended up going to New Hampshire
and in New Hampshire he made a statement
his wife was being attacked in the
middle of the so he he he won in the New
Hampshire primary and then his wife was
attacked by the press and he made an
emotional defense of his wife and in
that defense it looks like he was crying
right here's here's what the video looks
like gonna sound to be a gutless coward
maybe I said all I shouldn't
mr. fortunate for him he's not on this
platform beside me okay so he was ripped
up and down right he's ripped up and
down because he was supposedly crying
here it turns out that that was actually
just melted snowflakes because you can
see that it was snowing outside
but the press reported lying that the
muskie had broken down and cried and
that basically ended his candidacy right
that ended his candidacy so we used to
have a country where if you cried about
people attacking your wife then that was
considered wimpy now we have a cat now
we have a country where Cory Booker
whines about how he cried tears of rage
when he heard that the president said
something in a behind closed doors
meeting and we're supposed to take that
seriously
by the way Cory Booker is a serial
fabulist okay Cory Booker makes crap up
on a fairly regular basis there's a
story from a few years ago where Cory
Booker used to go around talking about
t-bone okay t-bone was a fixture of
Booker's unsuccessful 2002 mayoral bid
in Newark and he used to talk about his
friend at t-bone and his friends he bone
was alternatively a drug pusher would
threaten his life and then sobbed on his
shoulder according to Eliana johnson
she's now over at the Washington Post I
believe she was then a National Review
she says the tale is when Booker admits
he's told a million times but the in
Booker's mind according to city
councilmen it's not so much the details
of the story that matter but the
principle that these things happen they
happen to real people they happen in the
City of Newark the t-bone does not
apparently exist so there's a Rutgers
University history professor named
Clement price of Booker supporter he
told National Review Online he found the
mayor story offensive because it pander
to a stereotype of inner-city black men
t-bone Price says is a southern
inflicted name you would expect to run
into somebody or something named he bone
in Memphis not Newark Price said that he
was a mentor and friend to Booker and
says Booker conceded him in 2008 the
t-bone was a composite of several people
he'd met while living in Newark the
professor said that he told Booker he
disapproved of him inventing such a
person he said if you're gonna create a
compromising of a man along High Street
why don't you make a WB Dubois Booker
agreed that it was a mistake and then
Booker stopped talking about t-bone he's
never admitted by the way that t-bone
does not exist but he has defended
t-bones existence over and over this is
not the first time of course that he fib
in 2007
he described Newark activist Judi Diggs
as a potty mouth educator who was always
called cussing out my mama cussing out
my daddy and said she had died in truly
poetic way reading to children the Diggs
family was angry they came forward they
said that was a lie she died in her
office and then Booker emphasized that
his apology he apologized and said that
all of that was in bad taste and again
he's talked over and over about tea buns
I walked up to this charismatic black
guy my age called t-bone who was one of
the drug lords I just said yo man what's
up and he leapt in front of me looked me
right in the eye and said who the blank
do you think you are if you're so what
you look at me again I'm put a cap in yo
ass yeah this doesn't sound stilted at
all but that's who cory booker is and
now he's being trotted out as a hero so
this is the way we're gonna do this
whoever demonstrates the most emotion
whoever demonstrates I think it's true
on the right as well as on the left
whoever demonstrates the most emotion
wins I think this is one of the reasons
Trump won the nomination as could Trump
does angle really well Cory Booker is
not all that good at anger I mean again
that acting job is really not good it's
a really poor acting job but it allows
people I'm left to feel that he is
cathartic outlet for their emotions he
is an avatar for what I'm feeling I'm
feeling so mad and so angry and crying
tears of rage that Cory Booker is just
my guy how about this how about our
politicians don't have to be avatars of
your feelings heaven it's the stupidest
measure they say the most important
measure in presidential politics is
quote unquote cares about people like
you I think this is a stupid measure
because the way that people measure
caring typically is not what you do for
somebody else but how you feel about
somebody else
I hate intense based politics I hate it
I don't think that your intentions
matter nearly at all I don't think your
emotions matter nearly at all I think
that what you do matters right I'm of
the Batman school of thought right it's
it's it's not what's under the mask it's
what I do that defines me right that
that that's the school of thought that I
apply to politics I apply it to life as
well by the way I'm an axe based person
I'm happy with people and I think
they're doing the right thing I'm
unhappy wanting to do the wrong thing
but in politics too often it's oh they
care about people like me because they
shed a tear because I know that deep
down they care about my concerns how
about we stop worrying so much about how
people care and what they think about
their emotions and we worry more about
what they do
if we did that we'd have a doc I deal
probably in the next couple of days here
I mean while the Democrats are never
gonna stop with it's a dick Durbin
Wilmont stop he says the Trump says that
we need more Europeans we need more
people from Norway
again I find the the ire from dick
durbin over Trump saying that there are
bleep whole countries out there a little
bit ironic considering that he suggested
back during the Iraq war that American
soldiers were the equivalent of Nazis or
the soldiers of Pol Pot from Cambodia
now here at Senator Dick Durbin from
Illinois Bregan but it was a long
far-ranging meeting about immigration in
general negative things were said about
Haitians coming to the United States the
president was talking and I think this
is a tell if you will we need more
people from Norway he said Norway they
don't even take refugees in Norway said
and I just met with a Norwegian Prime
Minister and we need more Europeans we
need I mean it was pretty clear to me
what the president's message was in that
meeting okay okay well I'm glad that it
was clear to him but we're now a week
out and nothing has changed Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I think his probably is
right on this now we've wasted a week
fighting over Trump's verbiage behind
closed doors why don't we actually get
to the policy and then see if Trump
actually wants to take in refugees from
Norway but not Haiti how about that yeah
one of the rare times while sided with
with the the press secretary here's what
Sarah how could be Sanders said
yesterday look I wasn't in that room so
I can go only off of what the
individuals who were they said that term
wasn't used but that tough language was
look no one here is gonna pretend like
the president is always politically
correct he isn't I think that's one of
the reasons the American people love him
one of the reasons that he won and is
sitting in the Oval Office today is
because he isn't a scripted robot he's
somebody who tells things like they are
sometimes and sometimes he does use
tough language the point that he's
trying to make the point that the entire
conversation frankly should be focused
on is the issue at hand we've wasted
five days fighting over one word when we
should be fighting over the the people
that are involved in the daca program if
Democrats really want to protect these
individuals that's who they should be
fighting for and that's what they should
be fighting about is figuring out a
permanent solution to daca okay so it's
the end of this Agreement not the part
where Trump is politically incorrect
I always object to equating political
and correctness with with just being
offense
and silly but what she says at the end
here is right that why are we still
talking about this like why are we why
can't we move on from this you've
already made your minds up right you've
already made your decision what do you
want Trump to say at this point well you
really want Trump to say is I resign
you're not gonna get that what you
really want Trump to say is I was a
racist you're not gonna get that either
so I guess we can keep just beating
Trump about the ears on this comment but
it's pretty obvious what the agenda is
at this point okay meanwhile I in other
news there's more nonsense from the me2
movement feminists are freaking out as I
mentioned briefly yesterday at Margaret
Atwood the author of the the famed book
The Handmaid's Tale which is not a very
good book but she's considered a
feminist icon what did she do that's so
wrong what's she done to piss off me the
me2 movement well apparently there was a
piece that she that she signed about how
a guy named Steven Galloway the former
chair of the Creative Writing Program at
the University of British Columbia was
facing serious allegations and that
those allegations were not being
properly examined that people were
jumping to conclusions so Atwood pointed
to the university's lack of transparency
around the allegations and noted that
Galloway had been asked to sign a
confidentiality agreement she said quote
the public including me was left with
the impression this man was a violent
serial rapist and everyone was free to
attack him publicly since under the
agreement he had signed he couldn't say
anything to defend himself a fair-minded
person would now withhold judgment as to
guilt until the report and the evidence
are available for us to see when she
suggested this was like the Salem witch
trials and that guilt was assumed of
people who were accused a bunch of
people on the Left win nuts on this how
dare Margaret Atwood call for due
process how dare Margaret Atwood
suggests that we may not have all of the
facts the longer the Miche movement
continues with this the worse it's gonna
be for them because we all agree that
rape and sexual assault are bad but it
is not out of bounds to suggest that we
might need to see some evidence that in
the initial phase we can believe
objective claims about what a man has
done but we need all the facts to come
out and we need to hear what the guy has
to say about it as well but that's not
what the me2 movement apparently wants
to do the Huffington Post has a piece
that was leading last night about Aziz
Ansari I defended as he's done sorry a
couple of days ago I've been defending
him now for a couple of days not because
I think he's not a d-bag I think he is a
d-bag but because I think that if
there's any implication that he was
sexually assaulting or sexually
harassing this woman who came to his
apartment got naked and performed sex
acts on him multiple times before
deciding she wasn't having fun that
maybe she might have been sending some
mixed signals is that a possibility
like some mixed signals yeah I honestly
I don't think it's particularly mixed
when you get naked in the guy's
apartment and perform oral sex on him
twice like that doesn't seem
particularly mixed to me that's that's
pretty certain signal but apparently
Aziz Ansari is supposed to be a mind
reader so this is this article from The
Huffington Post talks again about
another story where a guy was not nice
to a woman and how it made her feel used
and we can't and we can't dismiss the
Aziz Ansari story as me to movement run
amok this is this writer says the sexual
encounter grace described falls into
what I see is a gray area of violating
non criminal sex the kind of sex rebecca
traced are described as bad in ways that
are worth talking about and what Jessica
Valenti described on Twitter is an
interaction that the culture considers
normal but it's oftentimes harmful
harmful well maybe that's because the
culture that the feminist movement
created has destroyed the notion of
normal sex maybe that's the problem and
maybe we should start deconstructing
that okay time for a couple things I
like a quick thing I hate and then Bible
talk so the things I like this is a
minor thing I like today but I did enjoy
Orrin Hatch who's gonna be the retiring
senator from Utah he was in the middle
of doing this questioning at the Senate
Judiciary Committee of the Homeland
Security Secretary and he saw it he
forgot that he was wearing he was not
wearing glasses and so this semi
hilarious moment ensued thank you mr.
chairman I'd like to begin with
crucially employee side him going for
those glasses that are not there and
removing them I've never worn glasses I
don't know if this is a regular thing
that people do I assume that it's
relatively common but duh minor thing
that I like today we don't have to go
any further than that okay time for a
quick thing that I hate
so my state California leads the nation
in poverty doesn't matter we have a 13%
state income tax does not matter we have
a 10% sales tax does not matter we spend
more money than any other state does not
none of that matters all the matters
that is the California continues to lead
the nation in poverty we are one of the
leaders in income inequality we have a
tremendous homeless problem if you drive
around LA it does look like a bleep hole
la has become very shoddy and run-down
the city of my birth and where I've
spent the vast majority of my life and
that does have something to do with the
city policy pursued by Democrats in city
governments in the City Council in the
mayor's office for years on end and
what's hilarious is that people on the
left continue to be puzzled by this how
could it be that California is just
terrible hell right it's in the the the
the report suggests that one out of five
residents the other time says one out of
five residents in California is poor so
California has fallen behind our state's
per capita GDP increase approximately
twice as much as the US average over the
five years ending in 2016 but the income
inequality has gotten worse because the
people who are making money at the top
of the spectrum are people in Silicon
Valley people in Hollywood people in the
finance industry but all the people at
the bottom are failing why because
because it is very difficult to start a
business and hire in in California
regulations are really difficult there
are eight hundred eighty three thousand
full-time equivalent state and local
employees in 2014 we have huge
bureaucracy we have a housing crisis
more than four in ten households spent
more than 30% of their income on housing
in 2015 that's because of regulations
preventing new building in places like
Los Angeles so you can't actually drive
the market down in terms of housing all
of this is what the people on the Left
have wanted they designed this policy
and now they own it California is in bad
shape because of progressive policies it
is simple it is just that simple there's
no more to it okay time for a quick
Bible analysis since it is Wednesday so
I felt like this is one of the most
moving portions of the Bible you know
for all the people who talk about the
Bible is sexist in the Torah is sexist
and now all these religious people are
so sexist this notion of how men and
women are supposed to operate is more
loving and more genuine and more real
and more committed than anything that
the feminist left has come
with and this is written at least 3000
years ago right this is written in at
the beginning of Genesis this is Genesis
chapter 2 verses 22 through 25 and the
Lord God built the side that he had
taken from man into a woman and he
brought her to man and the man said this
time it is the bone of my bones and the
flesh of my flesh this one shall be
called a Shaw woman because this one was
taken from each man therefore shall a
man leave his father and mother and
cleave to his wife and they shall become
one flesh and then here is the key line
right now they were both naked the man
and his wife but they were not ashamed
why weren't they ashamed why weren't
they ashamed because there's nothing
shameful about sex with a person to whom
you are married there's nothing shameful
about the idea of becoming one flesh
with the person who is your soulmate and
who is flesh of your flesh there is
nothing shameful about the person you
have chosen to create a life with having
sex with you or being naked in front of
you not only is there nothing shameful
about it there's something beautiful
about it but the beauty of sex is lost
when it just becomes a series of casual
one-night stands or when sex becomes
about physical impulse rather than a
spiritual of a physical desire to
fulfill a spiritual impulse you got rid
of commitment you got rid of love and
now you're upset because everything's
awkward
maybe it's because you made bad
decisions about how your sex life was
going to go and because Society has made
bad decisions to separate off
spirituality and meaning and intimacy
and closeness and love and commitment
from the sex act itself and once man's
reason pervades of one's man's just a
desire to change how sex works prevails
over the natural order and the natural
order is the idea that man and woman are
supposed to be in committed relations in
order in order to have sex with one
another right that's what the Bible is
saying here once that happens you
shouldn't be surprised when things go
awry and that's exactly what's happened
and that's why the me2 movement I think
is destined to fail because they refuse
to examine their underlying assumptions
about what male-female relationships
should look like where the two sides
owes something to one another and
therefore are not ashamed in the
presence of one another okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with much much more
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis lover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018